son discours à la nation était très
attendu de retour d'allemagne il ya
plusieurs jours après avoir été soigné
pour des complications post co vide
pendant plusieurs semaines abdelmadjid
tebboune multiplient les annonces pour
calmer la fronde politique et sociale
qui couve dans le pays
j'ai décidé d'un remaniement ministériel
dans les 48 heures je l'annoncerai
demain ou après demain et il inclura
tous les secteurs est les citoyens ainsi
que nous estimons qu'il ya un manque de
performance
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale populaire pour appeler à des
élections qui soient franchies de
l'argent qu'ils viennent de la
corruption ou non et d'ouvrir les portes
à la jeunesse des annonces qui
interviennent après des consultations
menées avec six formations politiques le
week-end dernier
autre geste d'apaisement la grâce
présidentielle accordée à une
cinquantaine de militants du irak dont
une trentaine condamnés en début de
semaine à des peines allant jusqu'à deux
ans de prison ferme
j'ai décidé d'accorder la grâce
présidentielle à une trentaine de
personnes environ pour lesquelles une
décision avait été rendue et d'autres
pour lesquels aucun verdict ce n'avait
été rendue entre 55 et 60 personnes
rejoindront à partir de ce soir ou
demain leurs familles
cette mesure survient à quelques jours
du deuxième anniversaire du irak
ce mouvement de protestation populaire
déclenchée en février 2019 et qui a
forcé abdelaziz bouteflika la démission
deux mois plus tard à l'arrêt depuis
mars 2020 en raison de la pandémie les
mobilisations se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours comme le 16 février à
kherrata berceau du mouvement
enfin dernières annonces du président
algérien
la production du vaccin russe coûte nick
v contre locaux vides 19 d'ici six mois
avec pour objectif de faire vacciner
vingt millions d'algériens soit la
moitié de la population du pays d'ici la
fin de l'année